all right well have you been getting out
on Drive still like are you using your
all those cars you don't know I'm here
in my garage right now this thing behind
me is called the 3d printer we use it to
make parts when I work on cars but he's
doing it we've been making these masts
and we make them for free and we the
machine runs 24 hours a day we got a
couple of them here and we turn out
these masks we just make this part this
plastic part another guy makes this part
and you saw put them on like this you
know like you wouldn't and we do mean
free we just make them afraid just turn
them out all day we give them to the
fire department they give them the first
responders so you feel like you're doing
something yeah I always tell people
maybe got old blankets maybe got things
you can give to the goodwill I mean
everybody can do something to help out a
little bit and that's kind of what we're
doing I mean I enjoy working on my cars
but this machine doesn't make parts all
the time so what we do is you just leave
the last two or three weeks you've had
it running this is all the spare pieces
here and we this is what they look like
that's so cool yeah and and we just we
bang these out and we give them the
first responders and who else where we
want something that's really cool and I
know you said it makes you feel good and
ever feel like you're helping me you are
helping that's a really incredibly cool
thing you could be like you said you
could just be like a lot of Americans
are sitting at home watching TV and
eating subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going